One of the most common questions we’ve been
asked over the years, right up there with
how blind people know they are done wiping
after going #2, is why blind people wear sunglasses.
After almost seven years of being asked this
question, we suppose it’s high time we answered
it.
It should first be noted that, contrary to
what many seem to think, not all blind people
are completely blind.
In fact, the vast majority of legally blind
people can see at some level, just very poorly.
For reference, the American Foundation for
the Blind defines blindness as:
a level of vision loss that has been legally
defined to determine eligibility for benefits.
The clinical diagnosis refers to a central
visual acuity of 20/200 or less in the better
eye with the best possible correction, and/or
a visual field of 20 degrees or less.
Often, people who are diagnosed with legal
blindness still have some usable vision.
(And if you’re wondering, see: How the 20/20
Vision Scale Works) This “usable vision”
point is important to note because it means
that these individuals, like their better
sighted brethren, can also be distracted or
otherwise disoriented by bright light, with
a pair of sunglasses being an easy solution
to the problem.
That said, while some blind people opt to
wear common store bought sunglasses to filter
out bright and ultraviolet light, others need
to wear specially made eyeshields that can
filter specific colors of light their eyes
are sensitive to.
On the UV light note, much like those of the
sighted persuasion, protecting the eyes from
UV radiation is of tantamount importance for
the blind, as it’s exceptionally dangerous
to the unshielded eye.
For example, overexposure to UV light can
potentially cause everything from cataracts
to inflammation of the cornea (photokeratitis)
or conjunctiva (photoconjunctivitis).
These latter two are essentially a sunburn
of the eye and are every bit as painful as
you might expect from that statement.
In some cases, excessive UV exposure to the
eye can even eventually result in certain
forms of ocular cancer.
Because many blind individuals have little,
or in some cases no, natural ability to detect
whether their eyes are being bombarded with
a bright light source potentially giving off
a lot of UV radiation, like the Sun, and thus
aren’t able to know when their eyes need
protecting from said light, they are more
at risk of falling victim to the various afflictions
associated with it.
Closer to Earth, some blind people opt to
wear sunglasses everywhere they go to protect
their eyes from physical dangers like low-hanging
branches, small objects blown by the wind,
open cupboard doors, etc.
Another, often overlooked, reason that blind
people choose to wear sunglasses is to signify
that they’re blind at a distance.
For example, the white cane carried by many
blind people is noted as being as much a signal
to others as it is a tool for a blind person.
In this sense, sunglasses in some settings,
such as when worn indoors, serve as an easily
observed, popularly known cue for visual impairment
at a distance.
Similarly some blind people wear sunglasses
for the benefit of others.
As explained by this blind gentleman, sighted
people often find it uncomfortable or awkward
to converse with a blind person as it’s
potentially difficult or impossible for the
blind individual to maintain proper eye contact.
Wearing dark sunglasses partially gets around
the problem.
In that case, the blind person simply needs
to look in the general direction of the person
talking to make it seem like they are making
normal eye contact.
A more personal reason some blind people opt
to wear sunglasses is to hide certain deformities.
As discussed by blind author Belo Cipriani,
After being sightless for a few months, I
soon met people whose eyes were scarred, shrunken
or deformed in some way.
However, they still had some level of vision
— whether it was light or movement perception
— and prosthetics would eliminate useful
sight.
Still, at social settings, they keep their
eyes from the public.
He goes on to note that some blind people
feel a desire to “look the part”, donning
glasses to conform to the accepted stereotype
of a blind person wearing sunglasses.
He states of this, “I often found people
in public telling me that I was faking it.
I was not comfortable enough with my blindness
to have some witty reply, and, at that time,
it was easier to conform.”
So to sum up, while reasons vary from person
to person, when stepping back a bit from the
specifics of the answer, in a very general
sense, blind people mostly have historically
worn sunglasses for the same basic reasons
sighted people do- to protect their eyes and
for aesthetic reasons.
It’s just that blind people’s eyes often
need a bit more protecting and there are additional
visual reasons for many blind individuals
to wear sunglasses than just looking cool
or fashionable.
So that’s historically; what about the emerging
future?
As technology has advanced recently on the
mobile computing front, blind individuals
are starting to see new reasons to wear some
form of glasses.
For instance, in 2015 Vision Technologies
began beta testing smart glasses that have
a camera and headphones built into them.
The device, in conjunction with the individual’s
mobile phone, continually scans the environment
and updates the wearer audibly on anything
important.
For instance, the software includes facial
recognition algorithms that tell the wearer
if the camera sees someone the wearer has
stored in its memory as an individual they
know.
It can even be set to remind the wearer how
they know the person, along with other pertinent
details about them.
Just as practically, it also recognizes objects
like a refrigerator or a bus stop, letting
the individual know if they are standing near
one.
On this latter point, it can even read markers
off an approaching bus so the wearer knows
if the bus is the one they want to get on.
Beyond this, it can read any text from a product
label, book, sign or the like, among many
other features.
Needless to say, as technology and software
continues to rapidly progress, this sort of
thing is likely to see more and more blind
people wearing some form of smart glasses